JOINING US ARE REGULARLY
SCHEDULED ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE ON
BUSINESS PROFESSIONS JUST A FEW
HOUSEKEEPING ITEMS. AND ADVANCE.
IF ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
A ROOM LIKE TO TESTIFY ON A
BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND AND
WE'LL ASK YOU TO APPROACH THE
MICROPHONE AT THE APPROPRIATE
TIME. YOU CAN EXIT THE ROOM
WHAT YOU'RE DONE TESTIFYING OR
RETURN. TO YOUR SEAT. IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM. WE ALSO HAVE
REMOTE TESTIMONY STATIONS
LOCATED. ON THE NORTH STEPS OF
THE CAPITOL BUILDING. FOR
DALLIN WITNESSES. THE ACCESS
CODE TO CALL IN FOR THE HEARING
IS EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
ACCESS CODE. IS TWO FOUR. TWO
SIX. TWO THREE SEVEN. AGAIN
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN
ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR. TWO
SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. CAN ALSO
FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE. AS WELL AS
YOUR TELEVISION. HI PLEASE NOTE
THAT THERE IS ONE ITEM ON
CONSENT THAT'S FILE ITEM NUMBER
FIVE IT'S S. B. TWO THIRTY TO
SIXTY THREE SKEWS ME AGAIN FILE
ITEM NUMBER FIVE. SB TWO SIXTY
THREE BY SENATOR RUBIO WILL BE
ACTING AS A SUB COMMITTEE.
SINCE THE LACK OF A QUORUM AND
IT WILL BEGIN THEN AND FOLLOW
ORDER WILL BEGIN THEN FOLLOW
ORDER NUMBER ONE. THIS IS
SENATE BILL FOUR ZERO NINE BY
SENATOR CABALLERO. I SEE
SENATOR CAFIERO HERE IN THE-
CHAMBERS. SENATOR COVER YOUR
THIS DOES ENJOY TO PASS
RECOGNITION BOTH SIDES BUT
WE'LL BE ACTING AS A SUB
COMMITTEE. PLEASE FEEL FREE TO
PRESENT MONEY FOR READY. VERY
GOOD THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT AS
BEFORE A NINE IN MAY TWENTY
TWENTY THE GOVERNOR ISSUED AN
EXECUTIVE ORDER A WAIVER OF
CERTAIN CLEA TESTING
RESTRICTIONS ALLOWING
PHARMACISTS TO ORDER KOBE TEST
AND COLLECT THE NECESSARY
SPECIMENS THE WAIVER REQUIRED
ONE IF THE TEST BE AUTHORIZED
BY THE FDA. TO THAT THE
PHARMACIST TO PHARMACISTS BE
COMPETENT AND TRAINED TO
COLLECT A SPECIMEN NEEDED FOR
THAT PARTICULAR TEST AND THREE
THE SPECIMEN BE COLLECTED
CONSISTENT WITH THE PROVISIONS
OF THE EMERGENCY USE US
AUTHORIZATION THAT WAS ISSUED
BY THE FDA. THE WAIVER ALSO
AUTHORIZED PHARMACISTS TO
SERVICE QUALIFIED LABORATORY
TESTING PERSONNEL BUT ONLY IN
THE APPROPRIATELY LICENSED OR
REGISTERED CLINICAL LABORATORY
UNDER THE DIRECTION OF A
LABORATORY DIRECTOR THIS BILL
WOULD CODIFY THAT WAIVER AND
FURTHER ALLOW PHARMACISTS TO
PERFORM ADDITIONAL WEIGHT CAST
AS OUTLINED IN THE BILL OR AS
APPROVED BY TE BOARD OF
PHARMACY. AND THE MEDICAL BOARD
OF CALIFORNIA MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES INCLUDING THOSE IN
MY DISTRICT FACE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES IN OBTAINING ACCESS
TO TESTING AND VACCINES FROM
THE ONSET OF THE PANDEMIC.
PEOPLE TRAVEL LONG DISTANCES IN
ORDER TO OBTAIN PRESCRIPTIONS
TESTING AND RECEIVED THEIR
VACCINES. MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES HAVE AT LEAST ONE
PHARMACY AND THESE LOCATIONS
HAVE BEEN KEY PILLARS AND
TRUSTED RESOURCES IN OUR
COMMUNITIES PRE PANDEMIC. AND
DURING THE PANDEMIC HAVE SERVED
AS LIFELINES TO OUR RESIDENTS
ESPECIALLY IN RURAL AREAS WHERE
AFFORDABLE ACCESS TO QUELL
QUALITY HEALTHCARE IS DIFFICULT
TO ACCESS. IS CRITICAL TO
UTILIZE THIS RESOURCE AND
HIGHLY SPECIALIZED TRAINING AND
EXPERIENCE OF EXPERIENCE OR
PHARMACIST TO EXPAND MUCH
NEEDED ACCESS TO HEALTH CARE IN
OUR COMMUNITIES. HERE TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF THE
MEASURE IS ANSATA GRAND WITH
THE STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
CABALLERO WITH THE BEGIN WITH
THE FIRST PRIMARY WITNESS IN
SUPPORT PLEASE LIMIT YOUR
TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES. OUR EXECUTIVE OFFICER
OF THE STATE BOARD OF PHARMACY.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRPERSON LOW. I
CARE FOR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE BOARD OF
PHARMACY I THANK SENATOR
HAPPIER FOR OFFERING THIS
IMPORTANT PUBLIC HEALTH
MEASURE. IN THE COMMITTEE AND
ITS STAFF FOR CONSIDERATION OF
THE MEASURE TODAY. THE BOARD OF
THE CONSUMER PROTECTION AGENCY
CHARGED WITH REGULATING THE
PRACTICE OF PHARMACY. SENATE
BILL FOUR NINE EMBODIES THE
BOARD VISION HEALTHY CALIFORNIA
THIRD QUALITY PHARMACIST CARE
THANK YOU NEED ACCESS POINTS TO
SPECIFY. CLEAR WAY TO PASS.
SENATE BILL FOREIGN. BILLS UPON
IT CURRENTLY FOR ISSUE BY THE
CARE ACT TO EXPAND K. CASTING
CAPACITY AND AFTER POINT FOR
CALIFORNIANS. I PROVIDE A
TEMPORARY THIRTY FOUR
PHARMACIST REFORM SUCH TESTS
AND EXPANDED TECHNICALLY
GRANTED UNDER THE PROVISIONS OF
SENATE BILL ONE FIFTY NINE IN.
TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN. IT'S
EXCEPT THE PHARMACIST PROVIDED
TESTING DEMONSTRATES THE
IMPORTANT ROLE PHARMACISTS CAN
PLAY IN PUBLIC HEALTH. THE
BOARD AT LEAST APARTMENT AND
EXPANDED AUTHORITY THOUGHT
SENATE BILL FOUR NINE IS IN THE
BEST INTEREST OF CALIFORNIANS
AND IT'S CONSISTENT WITH THE
KNOWLEDGE SKILLS AND ABILITIES
OF THE PHARMACISTS. A
PHARMACIST EDUCATION INCLUDES A
FOUR YEAR COLLEGE BACCALAUREATE
DEGREE IN PHARMACY UNDER THE
ACCREDITATION STANDARDS
<c.green>URRICULUM INCLUDES PUBLIC</c>
HEALTH MANAGEMENT STRATEGIES
NATIONAL COMMUNITY BASED PUBLIC
HEALTH PROGRAMS AND
IMPLEMENTATION OF ACTIVITIES.
THAT OUR PUBLIC HEALTH WELLNESS
WHICH ALIGN WITH THE POLICY
GOALS OF THE MEASURE PERMANENTE
FORTY FOR PHARMACIST ONE IS
TESTED SPECIFIED IN THE BILL IS
APPROPRIATE AND NECESSARY. TO
ENSURE CALIFORNIANS CAN
CONTINUE TO AVAIL THEMSELVES OF
THIS EXPANDED ACCESS POINT
THANK YOU. FOR YOUR TIME AND
YOUR CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU
VERY. WITHOUT ON TO TEST
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WISHING
TO TESTIFY. HERE THE TELEPHONE
CONFERENCE SYSTEM. THANK YOU SO
YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TELEPHONE KEYPAD.
AGAIN THAT'S ONE ZERO. YOU CAN
PURCHASE ORDER LINE NUMBER
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING CHAIRED COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THIS IS WHEN WE GO
AHEAD WITH THE CALIFORNIA
RETAILERS ASSOCIATION NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF CHAIN DRUG
STORES IN EUROPE STOCK
ACCORDING TO THE FOLLOWING
NIGHT THANK YOU. AND NEXT TO A
LINE GIVE ME JUST A MOMENT HERE
WE DO HAVE A COUPLE IN Q. HERE.
OR LINE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISS
CHARLIE DESPERATELY CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. Q. ONE MOMENT. AND
ACTUALLY GOT A LINE NUMBER
THIRTY SIX WHEN WE LOOK AT LINE
THIRTY SIX EUROPEN. AND THEY'RE
LYING DEAD STOP REMOVING
THEMSELVES FROM Q. NO FURTHER
IN Q. THANK YOU VERY MUCH WILL
NOW GO ON TO THE PUBLIC
CHAMBERS HERE. MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC PLEASE FEEL FREE PERCENT
OF READY. THE MORNING CARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS EMILY HUGHES
OF THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION ALTHOUGH THE
ASSOCIATION HAS NOT HAD TIME TO
TAKE AN OFFICIAL POSITION WE DO
APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR WORKING
WITH US. AND ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS IN THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THAT WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
OF. THANK YOU VERY MUCH SCENE
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING THE CHAMBERS. OR
IN OUR- OTHER EXTERNAL ROOMS.
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. YOU
END UP GETTING PAID LIKE TO
SPEAK IN OPPOSITION YOU'LL WANT
TO PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. AGAIN THAT'S ONE
ZERO. AND CURRENTLY OUR QUEUE
WITH AT ZERO. OKAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH NO OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES SIGNAL OPPOSITION
HERE IN THE GALLERY ANY
QUESTIONS ARE FOR COMMENTS FOR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AT THIS TIME.
DR WEBER. THANK YOU CHAIR THANK
YOU SENATOR CABALLERO- THANK
YOU FOR MY IMPROMPTU QUESTIONS-
I DO LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSING THIS BILL WITH YOU I
DO HAVE- SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THE EXPANSIVE SCOPE OF NATURE
THAT YOU'RE GIVING TO THE
PHARMACIST- WHEN YOU- AND THE
BELL NOW STATE THAT THE
PHARMACIST MAY PERFORM. ANY
ASPECT OF ANY FDA APPROVED TEST
I'M AND THEN YOU KNOW YOU'RE
GOING LISTS A BUNCH OF THEM.
THE PHARMACIST- YOU KNOW
ALTHOUGH THEY ARE VERY VERY
WELL TRAINED I WAS VERY
FORTUNATE. FOR MY OF MY COLLEGE
WE HAVE ONE OF THE BEST
PHARMACY SCHOOLS IN THE COUNTRY
AND SO MANY OF MY VERY VERY
VERY CLOSE FRIENDS A
PHARMACIST. SOME VERY FAMILIAR
WITH THEIR TRAINING THEIR SCOPE
OF TRAINING AND WHAT THEY'RE
NOT TRAINED FOR. AND SO WHEN I
LOOK SPECIFICALLY IN MY AREA
PRACTICE SAID- YOU KNOW S. T.
S. T. EITHER SECTOR TRANSMIT
INFECTIONS. KNOWING THAT THERE
IS AN FDA APPROVED A CLEAR TEST
FOR GONORRHEA AND CHLAMYDIA
WHICH WAS APPROVED IN APRIL OF
THIS YEAR. I DO WONDER WHETHER
OR NOT- THE PHARMACIST HAS THE
RIGHT TRAINING TO- COUNSELOR
PATIENT- WHO COMES IN AND THEN
OF COURSE THEY CAN'T PRESCRIBE
THE MEDICATION. SO AND THEN
LOOKING AT SOME OF THESE OTHER.
THINGS IN THE NEAR
CARDIOVASCULAR HEALTH. THE
IRATE ISSUES I DEFINITELY SEE
THE NEED TO EXPAND THE ABILITY
FOR PATIENTS TO HAVE ACCESS.
I'M JUST WONDERING IF MAYBE
THIS- EXPANSION IS JUST A
LITTLE TOO MUCH FOR THEIR FOR
THEIR TRAINING AND ALSO FOR
THEIR TIME PHARMACISTS ARE VERY
VERY BUSY INDIVIDUALS AND SO.
TO HAVE TO TAKE TIME TO THAN TO
COUNSELING FIRST SOME
CONDITIONS THAT ARE PRETTY
SIGNIFICANT- MAYBE IT AN EXTRA
BURDEN ON THEIR PLATE BUT I DO
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE BILL
I WILL BE SUPPORTING IT TODAY-
AND I DO LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO TALK WITH YOU.
ABOUT THIS- EXPANSION AND THEIR
SCOPE OF PRACTICE BUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR WHAT
WEBER. CENTER COMPARED TO WISH
TO CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND I WANT TO THANK DR WEBER
FOR THAT- LITTLE DISCUSSION WE
HAD RIGHT BEFORE WHAT'S
IMPORTANT ABOUT THIS BILL IS
THAT NOT ALL PHARMACISTS HAVE
TO DO THIS- IT'S REALLY A-
OPPORTUNITY. AND AND I- RICH I
WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
BUT BUT I LOOK FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THESE
CONVERSATIONS SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CENTER
COVER ALL IT. WAS STATUS A
QUORUM. HELLO HERE FLORETTE
HERE BERMAN. BLOOM CHEN Q.
CUNNINGHAM DALY FONG GIPSON
GRAYSON HOLDEN IRWIN MCCARTY
MEDINA MULLIN SALAS TANG WEBER.
CORMS BEEN ESTABLISHED OF A
STATUS QUO NOT TAKE THAT AS
MOTIONS BEEN FROM DOCTOR WEBER
AND ALSO SECOND FROM A SUMMER
GIPSON MUSIC TAPE PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SB FOUR OH NINE
CABALLERO TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI LOW HI
FLORA. FLORA ALL RIGHT BERMAN.
BLOOM CHEN CHEN AYE CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM DALLI DALLI HI FONG
FONG ALL RIGHT GIPSON GIPSON
GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE HOLDEN.
IRWIN. MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA HI
MULLIN SALAS CHANGE WEBER WEBER
I. SB FOUR NINE HAS NINE VOTES.
DO YOU BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN
FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER COVER
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. THAT
THE CALLS WILL GO TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO. THIS IS SB SEVEN
FIFTY SEVEN BY SENATOR LIMóN
SENATE LAMONT THIS GREEN CARPET
MATCHES YOU VERY WELL THIS DOES
ENJOY DO PASS RECOMMENDATION
BOTH SIDES THEY OUT PLEASE FEEL
FREE PRESENT WHATEVER READY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHAIR
MEMBERS. THANK YOU SINCE THE
BILL ALREADY HAS A MOTION AND
SECOND THAT I WOULD JUST GO
STRAIGHT TO MY WITNESSES- AS I
DO REMEMBER THE GREEN CARPET
WASTE- AND WE HAVE A LOT OF
THIS WILL BE THAT FROM THE LORD
IS WITH THE FOUNDATION AND
MICHAEL JANET. THAT SEEKS FROM
THE CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSING
BOARD TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENATOR LIMóN WE HAVE TO
SUPPORT WITNESSES- IF YOU COULD
KINDLY LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY NO
MORE THAN TWO MINUTES EACH
LET'S BEGIN WITH A
REPRESENTATIVE FROM THE DOOR
SUPPORT THE FOUNDATION. HELLO
CAN YOU HEAR ME YES WELCOME.
PERFECT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THIS NOVEMBER LEAVE US A
COMMUNITY ORGANIZER WITH THE
DOORS WORKING FOUNDATION AND
THEN IN STRONG SUPPORTER SB
SEVEN FIFTY SEVEN AND ALSO-
GRATEFUL- SPIRIT WERE AND ALF
OF OUR PARTICIPANTS. I WHEN WE
CAME ACROSS THIS ISSUE THREE OR
FOUR YEARS AGO NOW- I'VE DONE
THE THING NOT BE ANY HOPE AND I
AM VERY HOPEFUL TO STAY AND TO
GO BACK TO THEM IN COMMON THAT
WE HAVE THE LEGISLATURE THIS
SEASON POINTS OF PROTECTING OUR
CONSUMERS SOLAR ENERGY IS
NEEDED FOR OUR ENVIRONMENT AND
FOR A FAMILY FAVORITE OF MONEY
AND ENERGY. BUT WE ALSO NEED
PROTECTION FROM THE BUSINESS
CLASSES THAT HAVE. UP TO THE
STATE- SACRIFICE MANY FAMILIES
HAPPINESS AND WELLBEING SO I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THAT YOU AND
ALL THE COMMITTEES WILL BE
IMPORTANT TO HELP LOWER
CONSUMERS WHO HAVE BEEN
SUFFERING FROM FRAUDULENT
PRACTICES AND ALSO-
UNSCRUPULOUS PEOPLE WHO SPEAK
THE WAY TO TAKE ADVANTAGE OF
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES. OUR
COMMUNITY IS VERY VERY MUCH IN
NEED OF BEING SUPPORTED AND
ALSO BE MOTIVATED TO BECOME-
EARTH FRIENDLY INTOLERABLE
WEIGHT BUT WE DO NEED THIS
PRACTICE HAS BEEN BUSINESS TO
BE ETHICAL AND TO BE PRACTICAL
AND TO BE ALSO USEFUL FOR ALL
CONSUMERS IN CALIFORNIA I THINK
YOU SO MUCH FOR ALL THE WORK
THAT'S BEEN HAPPENING AND
ESPECIALLY OLDER TAX COURT. THE
PUT IN THREE YEARS OF WORK TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATION AND OUR FOUNDATION
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MOVE ON TO
MY CHEN SKI. FROM THE
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSING
BOARD. THE MORNING CARE BY
CHAIR MEMBERS- MY CONNECT. CFL
B. THE BOARD DID. TO THIS. THE
BILL CLARIFIES THE LAW AND THEN
THEY HUGH FROM KIND. AND
EVERYTHING. THAT LICENSE
COUNTRY. ARE REQUIRED TO COMPLY
WITH- I DO RELATE TO THE AND-
OF. ENERGY SECTOR. AND MANY
MADE WAY. NUMBER ONE ENSURE
THAT A COUNTRY RECORD. SOLAR
ENERGY THEM IN BEACON AT
APPROVED. AND TO RECEIVE
PROTECT- THE HOME IMPROVEMENT.
FIVE NEVER TO BUY. THEIR HOME
IMPROVEMENT SALES PERSON TO
BROKER THE SALE MUST BE
REGISTERED TO THE CONTRACT OR
THE CONTRACT AND THEY ARE
SOLICITING. NEGOTIATING ARE
EXECUTING CONTRACT FOR A GIVEN
TIME. AND THREE BY ENSURING
THAT THE RESTRICTION ON
CONTRACTORS- CONNECTION
THINKING AFTER WORK NOT
PERFORMED OR MATERIALS
DELIVERED. I HOME IMPROVEMENT
CONTRACT EXPAND HE GOES PAYMENT
THAT THEY'RE MADE BY THIRD
PARTY AS OPPOSED TO THE
HOMEOWNER. BUT THAT- A BAD
DEBTS THAT STATEMENT THIS
MORNING AND I APPRECIATE YOUR
TIME AND CERTAINLY AVAILABLE.
FOR ANY TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
THANK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF PUBLIC ON
THE FOR LINES TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITE AS WE CAN SUPPORT HE'S
ME OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO
SIGNIFY THEIR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT
THIS TIME IT'S SO. WE'LL GO
LINE TO LINE NUMBER FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
THIS IS ONE OF THE FOLLOWING
WITH THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
BANKING NETWORK AND SUPPORT.
AND MAN MAN FURTHER IN SUPPORT
OF THIS TIME THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SEEN ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE HELP
OF THE LINES. FOR ANY MEMBERS
OF THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME. IF
YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
CURRENTLY NO PARTICIPANT IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENIOR
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
THE CHAMBERS WISHING TO SPEAK
IN OPPOSITION AT THIS TIME WHEN
THEY MOVE ON TO ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THIS BEEN IN MOTION A SECOND
SENATOR LIBERTY WAS TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AND I HAVE
A THANK YOU VERY MUCH COMMITTEE
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN RAMON TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW HIGH LOW
HIGH FLORA. FLORA ALL RIGHT
BERMAN. BLOOM BLOOM HI CHEN
CHEN AYE CHIU. CUNNINGHAM DALLI
DALLI HI FONG HI FONG HI GIPSON
GIPSON HI GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN. IRWIN MCCARTY MEDINA
INA HI MULLIN SALAS TAKING
WEBER WEBER I. TEN I. ZERO
NOTICE. TEN I BELIEVE THE ROLE
OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL MEMBERS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SENATOR
LAMAR. ALWAYS MOVE ON TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER THREE WHICH IS S.
B. THREE SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR
NEWMAN WELCOME- WELL HI GOOD
MORNING THIS YEAR- THANK YOU
FOR HAVING ME TO YOUR HOME
SECOND. AB AND I APPRECIATE THE
KIND WELCOME. I MEAN JUST GO
STRAIGHT TO MY WITNESS THAT
SHAME CHANGE YOUR MINSKY A
PHARMACY MANAGER WHO WAS
RECENTLY INTERVIEWED BY NBC AS
PART OF THEIR EXPOSES ON
PHARMACY PRACTICE. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIR NEWMAN WILL MOVE
ON TO PRIMARY WIN ASSISTANCE
SUPPORT IF YOU KILEY KEEP YOUR
TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES EACH. PLEASE FEEL FREE
2% WHEN YOU'RE READY. THE
MORNING CARE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. MY NAME IS DR SHANE
GERMAN SKI. MY WIFE MARYLAND
AND I HAVE BEEN LIKE THE
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS FOR OVER
FOURTEEN YEARS. THEY'RE BOTH
FEATURED IN THE NBC NIGHTLY
NEWS PIECE THAT HIGHLIGHTED
SAFETY CONCERNS FACING OUR
PROFESSION. THE CONCERNS
REVOLVE AROUND ALL THE DIMPLED
ON PHARMACISTS AND TECHNICIANS
FOR THE SOLE PURPOSE OF
INCREASING PROFITS FOR
CORPORATE LEON CHAIN FARM.
UNFORTUNATELY DON'T CONCERNED
ABOUT ONLY EXACERBATED DURING
COLD AIR. I'M HERE TODAY TO
IMPORT EVERY LAWMAKER LISTENING
IF YOU SUPPORT PATIENT SAFETY
IF YOU SUPPORT THE HEALTHCARE
PROFESSIONAL THROUGHOUT OUR
STATE PLEASE VOTE IN FAVOR OF
SB THREE SIXTY TWO. MODERN DAY
PHARMACIST SUBMITTED EIGHT
YEARS OF RIGOROUS POSTSECONDARY
EDUCATION IN PREPARATION FOR A
LIFETIME OF SERVING THEIR
PATIENTS. WE CANNOT STAND IDLY
BY NOW WHILE PORT THE RETAIL
PHARMACY INTEREST MORE
POTENTIAL GROUP OF GLORIFIED
FAILED PEOPLE IN WHITE COATS.
ACCURACY EMPATHY AND GENUINE
HEALTHCARE WITH THE GOAL OF
EVERY GOOD PHARMACIST AND
TECHNICIAN. METRIC THAT
ATTEMPTS TO QUANTIFY ARE WORK
BASED ON NEED TO MAIL ORDER
AUTO REFILL ENROLLMENT FOR HOW
QUICKLY WE CAN ANSWER THE
PHONES ARE NOT ONLY ARBITRARY.
BUT A DANGER TO OUR PATIENTS.
AFTER TEN YEARS OF WORKING FOR
CORPORATE ON CHAIN PHARMACIES I
TRANSITION TO WORKING IN
INDEPENDENT PHARMACY PRACTICE.
THE DIFFERENCES CANNOT BE
UNDERSTATED PHARMACISTS CAN
SAVE HEALTH CARE DOLLARS SAFE
TRIP THE CLINIC THIRTY YARDS
AND LITERALLY SAVE PATIENTS
LIVES WHEN GIVEN THE TIME AN
OPPORTUNITY TO DO SELF.
INTEREST OF TIME TODAY I WILL
CONCLUDE MY COMMENTS I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO ADDRESS TODAY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR
NEXT PRIME ME WITNESSES SUPPORT.
THE MORNING SHERMAN AT A HOUSE
IN NUMBERS AND HOW IT ON BEHALF
OF UNITED. MARTIAL WORKERS UP
OVER A HUNDRED EIGHTY THOUSAND
NUMBERS MANY THOUSANDS OF WHOM.
ARE PHARMACISTS PHARMACY
TECHNICIANS AND PHARMACY STAFF
THE POLICE TO CO SPONSOR THE
FELLOW WITH A PARTNER TO
CALIFORNIA PHARMACISTS.
PHARMACY ASSOCIATION ONE THANK
YOU COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR ALL
THE EXCELLENT WORK- THEY DID IN
HELPING ME OUT WITH MY
NECESSARY FOR AFTER ON BOTH ON
THE STATION PROTECTION MEASURES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES FOR ANY ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS. TO SIGNIFY THEIR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. AND IF SO
PLEASE ONE ZERO AT THE TIME.
AND GIVE IT JUST A MOMENT HERE
FIRST WE'LL GO TO LINE OF
NUMBER THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI GOOD MORNING CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER MALLEY
WITH THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT OF THAT
SB THREE SIXTY TWO THANK YOU.
AND NEXT WEEK NOT A LINE OF
FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING ZACHRY CORP- WITH
THE CALIFORNIA DENTAL
ASSOCIATION WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND NEXT
SOBRE LINE OF. NUMBER FORTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
TERRY MEMBERS US WITH THE WITH
THE WHITE AMENDMENTS ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SOCIETY OF
HEALTH SYSTEM PHARMACISTS AND
SUPPORT. AND CURRENTLY NO
FURTHER ACTION AND CAN KEEP.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEE THAT
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN THE
CHAMBERS HERE PLEASE FEEL FREE
TO SIGNIFY YOUR SUPPORT. EMILY
HUGHES CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH SEE NO ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HEARING
THE CHAMBERS ARE ON THE PHONE
LINES WISHING TO SIGNIFY THEIR
SUPPORT OPERATOR WOULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
ANY ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC LISTING TO. SIGNIFY
THEIR OPPOSITION. AND SO PLEASE
PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY NOT IN Q. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH WILL MOVE THE
CONVERSATION THEN BACK TO
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION A SECOND
SENATOR NEWMAN TO WISH TO
CLOSE- THANK YOU MISTER I JUST.
LIKE TO THANK THE WITNESSES BUT
ALSO SPECIAL THANK CHIEF
CONSOLED ROBBIE SUMMER- FOR
WORKING ANY AMENDMENTS DESPITE
BEING ON LEAVE SO THOSE
pBILL THEY ALSO. LED THE
CALIFORNIA RETAILERS
ASSOCIATION MOVE THEIR
OPPOSITION- AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SENTIMENT. TWENTY SIX VERY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. SB THREE
SIX TWO NEWMAN TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HI LOW HI FLORA. FLORIDA ALL
RIGHT BERMAN BERMAN NIGHT BLOOM.
BLOOM HI CHEN Q. CUNNINGHAM
DALLI DALLI HI FONG FONG HI
GIPSON GIPSON GRAYSON. HOLDEN
IRWIN. WHEN I MCCARTY MEDINA
ENOUGH TIME MULLIN MULLIN HI
SALAS TEAM WEBER WEBER I.
ZERONOS ELEVEN I BELIEVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS THANK YOU SURE THANK
YOU MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AND NEWMAN. BECAUSE WE WAIT
WHILE WE WAIT FOR ADDITIONAL
AUTHORS. IF THEY CAN GET A
MOTION ON CONSENT. THIS IS OUR
FOR FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE S. B.
TWO SIXTY THREE. K. MOVE BY A
SUMMER BLOOM. SAY BY CHAIR
FLOOR PROTECTOR PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CONSENT ITEM S. B. TWO
SIX THREE RUBIO TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS LOW HI LOW HI
FLORA FLORA HI BERMAN. BERMAN I
BLOOM BLOOM I CHEN. CHEN AYE
CHIU CUNNINGHAM DELLY DELLY HI
FONG FONG I GIPSON. GRAYSON
HOLDEN. IRWIN IRWIN HI MCCARTY
MEDINA MEDINA HI MULLIN MULLIN
AYE SALAS KING WEBER WEBER HI.
GIPSON HI. TWELVE R. ZERO KNOWS.
IT'S OUR SYSTEM WHERE.
OR OKAY.
WE JUST MAKE AND THAT'S WHAT
THEY'RE CALLING THAT WE'RE JUST
WAITING FOR ADDITIONAL SENATORS
I KNOW THAT ARE SERGEANTS HAVE
KINDLY CALL THEM CENTERS WILL
ADJOURN THIS MEETING IN FIVE
MINUTES IF YOU DON'T HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL AUTHORS WOULD YOU
KINDLY MAKE YOUR WAY. HERE TO
THE ASSEMBLY CHAMBERS THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES WILL NOW MOVE ON TO
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOR THIS IS S.
B. THREE ZERO SIX BY DR PAN
DOCTRINE WELCOME THANK YOU
THINK OF ITS CHAIR- MEMBERS
ALWAYS APPRECIATE TO SUMMER
GIPSON DIRECTIONS OF GOT HERE-
THANKS VERY MUCH FOR HAVING ME
HERE WE'RE AT A CRISIS POINT
WHEN IT COMES TO STD INFECTIONS
IN THIS COUNTRY THE CDC
ESTIMATES THAT ONE IN FIVE.
WELL IN THE UNITED STATES HAVE
AN STD. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN
ALMOST SIXTY EIGHT MILLION STD
INFECTIONS REPORTED AND RATES
OF SYPHILIS CHLAMYDIA AND
GONORRHEA- UP FORTY PERCENT. TO
TWENTY THIRTEEN. THIS CRISIS
AFFECTS COMMITTEES ACROSS THE
STATE THE CALIFORNIA YOUTH
PEOPLE OF COLOR CASE SEXUAL. I
SEXUAL TRANSGENDER PEOPLE ARE
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTED.
OVER HALF OF ALL THE CITIES IN
THE STATE ARE REPORTED AMONG
YOU. AFTER AMERICANS ARE 5100%
MORE LIKELY TO CONTRACT HONOREE
INCLUDE MANY OF THEM TO WHAT
COUNTERPARTS. THESE DISPARITIES
ARE EXPECTED TO WORSEN AS A
RESULT OF THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC. CALIFORNIA HAD THE
SECOND HIGHEST SYPHILIS RATES
IN THE NATION IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. BETWEEN TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT TWENTY EIGHTEEN SYPHILIS
RATES AMONG WOMEN REPRODUCTIVE
AGE INCREASED BY SEVEN HUNDRED
FORTY THREE PERCENT. WELL THE
HARDEST DATA POINTS FOR ME TO.
SQUARE WITH HAS TO DO WITH THE
RATES OF CONGENITAL SYPHILIS A
CONDITION WE HOPE THAT WHICH IS
TREATABLE AND WE- HOPE THEY GOT
AWAY WITH THE VICTORIAN ERA AND
TWENTY EIGHTEEN MORE THAN THREE
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE BABIES WERE
BORN WITH CONGENITAL SYPHILIS
IN CALIFORNIA. A 9100% INCREASE
SINCE TWENTY TWELVE. AND THAT
YEAR TWENTY STILL BIRTHS WERE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE DISEASE.
HAPPEN CAN JOSEPH LIST CASES
OCCUR BECAUSE OF GAPS IN
TESTING AND TREATMENT DURING
PRENATAL CARE. THIS BILL WILL
INCREASE ACCESS TO STD
SCREENING AND TREATMENT BY.
INCREASING USE OF CALIFORNIA'S
EXPEDITED PARTNER THERAPY
COMMITTEE HIV COUNSELOR SAID MR
RAPID STDS TESTS OPENING UP
ACCESS TO THE FAMILY PACK
PROGRAM REQUIRING INSURANCE
COVERAGE FOR HOME STD TESTING.
AND REQUIRE A DISH CIVIL
SCREENINGS AND PRENATAL CARE.
SB THREE OH SIXTY SIX
COMPREHENSIVE APPROACH TO
ADDRESSING CALIFORNIA'S AS HE
CRISIS EXPANDING ACCESS IN AN
EQUITABLE WAY- I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE AND I HAVE
TO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH DOCTOR PAN. WILL
BEGIN THEN WITH YOUR TWO
PRIMARY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU COULD KINDLY WOULD LIMIT
YOUR TESTIMONY TO NO MORE THAN
TWO MINUTES EACH. AND WILL
BEGIN WITH DOCTOR GERRY RICH
WALLED. GOOD MORNING SHARE LOW
AND ASSEMBLY COMMITTEE MEMBERS
MY NAME IS DR GERRY RICH WALLED
I'M A PHYSICIAN AND
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE EXPERT.
FORMER DIRECTOR IN CHIEF
POSITION OF L. A. COUNTY AS THE
PROGRAM THE LARGEST. IN THE
COUNTRY AND I TEACH AT THE
EPIDEMIOLOGY AT THE USC TECH
SCHOOL OF MEDICINE CURRENTLY.
CALIFORNIA HAS NOT DEPEND SAID
FIVE SELF AND UNFORTUNATE
PREDICAMENT. IN THE MIDST OF A
SERIES OF STD EPIDEMIC SINCE
THE YEAR TWO THOUSAND TEN. WITH
THAT INCREASES OVER THAT TIME
PERIOD. UP THREEFOLD IN THE
FULLEST TO SPALDING GONORRHEA.
AND CHLAMYDIA BY HALF AGAIN AND
WHAT DOCTOR PAN SAID WHICH I
WANT TO RE EMPHASIZE. IS THAT
WE'VE HAD A TEN FOLD INCREASE
IN CONGENITAL SYPHILIS WHICH
MEANS THAT PREGNANT MOTHERS AND
THE MOST VULNERABLE FUTURE
CALIFORNIA IS THAT IS. THAT IS
NEWBORNS AND FETUSES. END UP
WITH A DEBILITATING OR FATAL
ILLNESS THAT IS FULLY
PREVENTABLE. SO HOW DOES THIS
BILL ADDRESSED THE ISSUE NUMBER
ONE INCREASES EXPEDITED PARTNER
THERAPY SO IF YOU HAVE
GONORRHEA. INFECTED YOU GET
MEDICATION THAT YOU CAN GIVE TO
YOUR SEX PARTNERS SO THEY CAN
BE TREATED AS WELL. THIS IS
DONE IN CLOSE TO FIFTY STATES
IN THE UNITED STATES NUMBER TWO
IT REQUIRES THAT THE SCREENING
IN THE THIRD TRIMESTER OF
PREGNANCY. I WAS HEAD OF THE
TEAM THAT USED THEIR IN THE
NINETEEN NINETIES TO ADDRESS
OUR PREVIOUS CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS EPIDEMIC AND IT WAS A
CRITICAL TOOL IN BRINGING THAT
UNDER CONTROL AND LAST BUT NOT
LEAST DURING THE CALL THAT THE
DAMAGE. WE'VE SEEN IN MANY
AREAS A 90% REDUCTION IN
SCREENING FOR STDS AND
IDENTIFICATION OF INDIVIDUALS.
WHO ARE INFECTED SO THEY CAN BE
TREATED. SB THREE OH SIX LEVELS
THE PLAYING FIELD. DURING THE
CALL THAT EPIDEMIC PEOPLE HAVE
TO PAY OUT OF POCKET. TO DO
REMOTE TESTING IN THEIR WHOLE
COLLECTING SPECIMENS AND A
SENDING THEM INTO THE
LABORATORY. THIS BILL REQUIRES
THAT INSURANCE COMPANIES PAY
FOR REMOTE HOME COLLECTION
WHICH USES NEW TECHNOLOGY YOU
KNOW USES WELL ESTABLISHED NEW
TECHNOLOGY. TO ACHIEVE AN
IMPORTANT GOAL SO S. C. THE
THREE CHARACTERS THE SB THREE
OF SIX IS AN IMPORTANT STEP
TOWARDS CREATING AN EQUITABLE
HEALTH CARE SYSTEM. SO THAT
INDIVIDUALS HAVE MUCH BETTER
ACCESS TO STD TESTING AND
TREATMENT. FOR ALL OF THESE
REASONS I URGE YOU TO VOTE YES
ON SB THREE OF SIX. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH DOCTOR RECALLED WE
NOW HAVE A SECOND PRIMARY
WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
REPRESENTING THE BLACK WOMEN
FOR WELLNESS ACTION PROJECT.
GOOD MORNING PARENTS MEMBERS MY
NAME IS WILLIAM AGAIN I'M
REPRESENTING BLACK ONES ONE IS
ACTUALLY PROJECT WE ARE
REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE KIEDY
BASED ORGANIZATION WITH OFFICES
IN LOS ANGELES AND STOCKTON AND
ARE COMMITTED TO IMPROVING THE
OVERALL HEALTH STATUS AND WELL
BEING A BLACK WOMEN AND GIRLS.
FOR DECADES CALIFORNIANS IN THE
STEADY INCREASE AND WE'VE HEARD
IN THE RATES OF STI AND CURRENT
DATA TELLS US THAT THESE
DIAGNOSES ARE NOW THE HIGHEST
IN THIRTY YEARS. YOU BLACK
FOLKS IN LGBTQ PLUS FOLK BEAR
THE DISPROPORTIONATE BURDEN OF
DETECTION THESE THESE FIGURES
THESE RISING STI RATES IN OUR
STATE ARE NOT ONLY EMBLEMATIC
OF THE SHORTCOMINGS OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE AND THE WAY IT
IS FILLED OUR COMMUNITY.
PARTICULARLY THOSE WHO ARE
MARGINALIZED THEY ARE CANARIAN
THE COAL MINE EARLY WARNINGS OF
THE GREAT IMPACT FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH SHOULD WE FAIL TO
IMPLEMENT INTERVENTIONS THAT
ARE INNOVATIVE AND RESPONSIVE
TO THE ISSUES ARE FACTORS THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO THE STAGGERING
RATE. CRITICAL ISSUES SUCH AS
LACK OF ACCESS TO HEALTHCARE
AND LACK OF ECONOMIC MOBILITY
INCARCERATIONS WE'VE HEARD THE
SOBERING FIGURES EARLIER
PRESENTATION ENSURING ACCESS TO
TESTING AND TREATMENT ARE KEY
TO EFFECTIVELY ATTRACTING
CALIFORNIA YEAH I CRISIS. SB
THREE OH SIX DOES JUST THAT AS
WE'VE HEARD BY AMONG OTHER
THINGS ENCOURAGING THAT
EXPEDITED PARTNER THERAPY
TREATMENT A PRACTICE BEING
DEFECTIVE FOR PARTNER
MANAGEMENT BY THE CDC EXPANDING
ACCESS TO AT HOME TESTING AS
WELL AS UPDATED BEFORE TESTING
PROTOCOLS FOR PREGNANT PEOPLE.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY IMPORTANT
GIVEN THAT 50% OF PEOPLE WITH
THE FOLKS IN THE STATE ARE
PREGNANT IN FACT CONGENITAL
SYPHILIS INCREASED 40%
NATIONWIDE WITH 25% OF THOSE
CASES FROM CALIFORNIA ALONE. I
MEAN LOOK CAN BE TREATED WITH
ANTIBIOTICS THAT COST LESS THAN
A DOLLAR SO BOLSTERING OUR
SCREENING PROTOCOLS SUCH THAT
SO THAT WE CAN DETECT TREAT AND
PREVENT IS CRITICAL AS LACK OF
TREATMENT IN THE ALTERNATIVE
CAN RESULT IN PERMANENT DAMAGE.
CALIFORNIANS CERTAINLY MADE
STRIDES TO EXPAND ACCESS TO
HEALTHCARE HOWEVER JACKSON
ACCESS TO STI SCREENING. AND
TREATMENT PROCESS WE HAVE THE
TOOLS TO REVERSE THE UPWARD.
TREND AND WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO INTERVENE
CALIFORNIA TO THE AND- IN OUR-
PUBLIC HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE SO
IT'S TO ENSURE. ACCESS TO CARE
AND BECAUSE THAT. FOR THOSE
THREE THEN I DO. URGES I'VE ON
AND THREE OF SIX- AS IT ALLOWS
US TO MAKE NECESSARY
INVESTMENTS IN OUR CARE AND
FIRST. THANK YOU VERY FOR YOUR
NOW QUESTION TO- THANK YOU VERY.
I WHICH PLEASE HELP THE LINE
FOR ADDITION MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SIGNIFY THEIR
SUPPORT. THANK YOU AND IF SO
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WELL FIRST GOT WIND OF
NUMBER FORTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LYDIA FOR REPRESENTING
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA DIVISION
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT
LINE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YOUR MEMBERS GET THE
MOST PROGRAM WE HAVE THE SAN
FRANCISCO AIDS FOUNDATION PROUD
BECAUSE MONSTER MUST BE THREE
OH SIX YOUR SUPPORT. NEXUS LINE
FORTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS
BUT I THINK HE AND ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
FAMILY PHYSICIANS IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE A SIX. MXF LINE. FORTY
NINE. I'M VERY GOOD TEARS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LIFE
SCIENCES IN SUPPORT. ANNEX
REDLINE TWENTY SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MISTER
TURNER NUMBER OF AN EVENT ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA NURSES
MIDWIVES ASSOCIATION AS WELL AS
NAY AROUND PRO CHOICE
CALIFORNIA SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXUS LINE. FIFTY GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CRACKLE
COOPER ON BEHALF OF A QUE LA
HELL A PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT. NEXT IN LINE
FORTY TWO. THANK YOU SURE
MEMBERS RUNNING AFTER EASTER
WITH THE WHITE MAN GROUP ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF HEALTH SYSTEM
PHARMACISTS IN SUPPORT. NEXT
DOOR LINE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MEDICARE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS SOVIET
CASTEEL WITH A PENCIL AFFECT
HOW A PROUD CO SPONSOR SB SIX
IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT DEADLINE EIGHTEEN. DR
DONALD LINEMAN WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF
PREVENTIVE MEDICINE IN THE
SUPPORT. NEXT DEADLINE. THIRTY
FOUR. THANKS FOR YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. NEXT TO LINE FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LINE FIFTY ONE
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING
MR TEARING NUMBER THIRTY ARMS
FROM ON BEHALF OF THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVE IN SUPPORT OF
SB THREE ZERO SIX. AND
CURRENTLY NO FURTHER IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ARE THERE
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC HERE
IN THE GALLERY WISHING TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT SEE NON OPERATIVE
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN OPPOSITION WOULD
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION.
ON S. B. THREE ZERO SIX. IF SO
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
OR STREETCAR LINE OF FIFTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ARE THEY TOOK
US OUT BY THAT POLITICS NEXT
WATER LINE. THIRTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THIRTY FOR YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. I AM THIRTY FOUR WE
CAN'T HEAR YOU. AND WILL MOVE
ON TO LINE FORTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MORNING PRESS THREE AND
FOR THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU. AND CURRENTLY NO
FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SEEN ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN OPPOSITION
WILL BRING THE CONVERSATION
BACK TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I WILL BEGIN WITH
THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INFECTIOUS
DISEASES ASSEMBLY MEMBER GIPSON.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
WHAT I THINK THE OFFER BRING IT
IS GOOD SENSIBLE A MEASURE
BEFORE US TODAY. I WOULD LIKE
ONE FOR TO BE CONSIDERED AS A
CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL. I DIDN'T
UNDERSTAND IT AT FIRST UNTIL
YOU ARTICULATION I'M HERE TODAY
IT ABSOLUTELY MAKES SENSE WHEN
YOU LOOK AT BARRIERS AND ALSO
ACCESS- TO HEALTHCARE- I'M
CARRYING A BILL ASSEMBLY BILL
TEN THIRTY EIGHT. I WHICH IS
THE HEALTH EQUITY PROGRAM TO
EMPOWER CLINICS AND CERTAINLY
THIS WOULD POWER THAT COMMUNITY
WHAT WE'VE SEEN- THE AND THE
DATA WAS SAP WAS ABSOLUTELY
SHOW- THAT BECAUSE OF THIS
PANDEMIC- S. T. EYES- OTHER
SIXTY TREATMENT TRANSMITTED
DISEASES HAS. INCREASED
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE STATE AND
SO WE HAVE TO TRY TO DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN. TO TO TEAR
DOWN BARRIERS INCREASE ACCESS
TO CARE AND SO ON I THINK THE
AUTHOR BRING IT IS SENSIBLE
MEASURE BEFORE US. AND LOOK
FORWARD TO VOTING I AND ALSO.
AS A CO AUTHOR OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. THANK VERY MUCH OF
SOME GIPSON DR WEBER. THANK YOU
CHAIR I TOO WOULD LIKE TO THANK
THE AUTHOR DR PAN FOR THIS
BILL- AS AN OBGYN IT IT REALLY
MEANS A LOT TO BE ABLE TO-
TREAT YOUR PATIENTS PARTNER
WITHOUT NECESSARILY KNOWING
THAT INDIVIDUALS INFORMATION OR
HAVING THEM COME INTO THE
CLINIC. OMINOUS IS VERY TRUE
AND I ADOLESCENT POPULATION
WHICH ACTUALLY HAS THE HIGHEST
RATES OF STI IS BEING ABLE TO
GET THAT OTHER PARTNER IN THERE
SO MANY DIFFERENT BARRIERS TO
THAT SO REMOVING THAT BARRIER
AND BEING ABLE TO GIVE THE
PRESCRIPTION TO THE PATIENT.
AND ANOTHER ONE FOR THEIR
PARTNER WITH JESSE EXPEDITED-
PATIENT TREATMENT ON THERE FOR
THE PHARMACIST TO FILL REALLY
IT'S A GAME CHANGER SO THANK
YOU SO VERY MUCH FOR THAT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH DR WEBER
AND DIGITAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. C. NINE.
UNDER PAN ALL IS SIMILARLY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRING
THIS BACK FOR WHEN WE TOOK A
LOOK AT THE COMMITTEE I TOLD
COMMITTEE STAFF. ESPECIALLY AS
ALSO SERVING AS CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LGBT LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS THAT THIS IS ABSOLUTELY
SHOULD BE A PRIORITY FOR US-
AND MAKE A MISTAKE THANK YOU
VERY MUH ALSO FOR LOOKING AT
THE SCIENCE BEHIND THIS. I
THINK WE NEED WITH RESPECT TO
SITE BEING SEX POSITIVE IN
UNDERSTANDING THAT THESE THINGS
ARE OCCURRING AND LET'S REMOVE
AS MUCH STIGMA AS POSSIBLE AND
PROVIDE ACCESS IS ABSOLUTELY
CRITICAL AND IN MANY
COMMUNITIES ARE STILL GREAT
STIGMA AROUND ITSELF. VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOU CHAMPIONING THIS
ISSUE AND- WOULD ALSO LIKE TO
PRIVILEGED TO BE ADDED AS A CO
AUTHOR AS WELL WOULD YOU WISH
TO CLOSE. WELL THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YEARS AT THE THAT THE
COMMENTS OF SUPPORT LOOKING
FORWARD TO ADDING BOTH THE
CENTER GIPSON AND WELL AS
SACCO- AT THE TOP THERE'S A
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND ENTRUSTING THIS
ISSUE ESPECIALLY LAST NIGHT BUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
DOCTOR PAN WE HAVE A MOTION BY
A SIMILAR GIPSON SECOND
BIOSIMILAR BERMAN. COMEDIC TAKE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. S. THREE
OH SIX PAN TO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS LOW. HIGH LOW
HIGH FLOOR. FLOOR NO BERMAN
BERMAN HI BLOOM LOOM HI CHEN.
CHIU CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM HI
DALY DELANO FONG. FONG HI
GIPSON GIPSON AYE GRAYSON MASON
I HOLDEN HOLDEN IRWIN IRWIN HI
MCCARTY MEDINA MEDINA HI MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE SALAS TEAM WEBER
WEBER HI. TWELVE AYE AYES TO
NOES CENTER PENDANT HAS TWELVE
I SAID MAYBE JUST A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION TO I JUST HEARD
IN TESTIMONY AS WELL THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN STD AND STI
WHEN YOU GIVE SOME
CLARIFICATION ON THE
DISTINCTION BETWEEN THE TWO.
STDC AS FOR SEXY TRANSMIT
DISEASE STI SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTION SO THEY
USUALLY USE SOMEONE'S
ANONYMOUSLY BUT- BRIDGET THAT
SOMETIMES THERE CAN BE SOME
CONFUSION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EXPECT
CULTIVABAN TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX THIS IS SB. FIVE TWENTY
FOUR BY SENATOR SKINNER. SENATE
SKINNER PLEASE FEEL FREE
PERCENT MURDER READY WELCOME.
THANK YOU CHAIR THANK YOU
MEMBERS. FIRST I'D LIKE TO-
EXCEPT THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS WHICH CLARIFIED THAT
THE FINANCIAL INCENTIVES. CAN
BE COMMUNICATED TO PATIENTS
AND- REMOVES THE LANGUAGE
ALLOWING PHARMACIES TO OFFER.
PRICE MATCHING FOR THOSE
FINANCIAL INCENTIVES I
APPRECIATE THE GOOD WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE ON- THE POINT OF
SB FIVE TWENTY FOUR. IS TO
ALLOW PATIENTS TO USE THE IN
NETWORK PHARMACY OF THEIR
CHOICE AS MANY OF US KNOW WE
MAY HAVE A LONG TERM
RELATIONSHIP WITH OUR
PHARMACIST THERE MAY BE AN IN
NETWORK PHARMACY CLOSE BY.
THERE COULD BE ANY NUMBER OF
REASONS WHY WE PREFERRED THE IN
NETWORK PHARMACIES. HOWEVER
THERE'S BECOME A TREND WHERE-
PATIENTS BENEFIT MANAGERS THAT
SOME- PRESCRIPTION BENEFIT
MANAGERS RATHER. TRY TO STEER.
THE PATIENT TO A SPECIFIC
PHARMACY AND IMPLY THAT THEY
HAVE NO CHOICE BUT ONLY TO USE
THAT PHARMACY. SO WHAT THIS
BILL DOES IS BASICALLY OF
COURSE THE PRESCRIPTION BENEFIT
MANAGER CAN STILL OFFER A
DISCOUNT TO THE PHARMACY OF
THEIR CHOOSING THEY CAN DO A
VARIETY OF THINGS- BUT IF THE
IF THE PATIENT'S STILL WANTS TO
USE THE IN NETWORK PHARMACY OF
THEIR CHOOSING. THEY CAN'T SO
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF IT AND
LET ME HAVE MY WITNESSES JIM
GROSS FROM CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION AND
CREEK POSTER FOR FROM A PL A
HEALTH TEST BY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATOR SKINNER. LET'S
MOVE ON TO PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY
TO NO MORE THAN TWO MINUTES.
OUR MEDICARE MEMBERS JIM GROSS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PHARMACISTS ASSOCIATION PERSONA
THANK MR K<c.cyan> FOR VERY HARD</c>
WORK OVER THE LAST WEEK-
WORKING ON AMENDMENTS AND
REACHING A POINT WHERE WE HAVE
ACCOMMODATED SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION- AS SENATOR-
SKINNER SAID- THIS IS NEVER
GOING PRACTICE BY LARGE-
CONGLOMERATES- THAT ARE TRYING
TO CONTROL. THE DISPENSING OF
PRESCRIPTION DRUGS THROUGH
THEIR- BRICK AND MORTAR
PHARMACIES AND THROUGH THEIR
MAIL ORDER AND WHILE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT- THERE IS VALUE
TO BOTH MAIL ORDER IN SOME OF
THE PHARMACIES OWNED BY- THESE
GLOBAL CONGLOMERATES- WE DO NOT
BELIEVE IT'S IN THE PATIENT'S
BEST INTEREST. TO ARBITRARILY
STEER THEM AWAY FROM THE
PHARMACIES THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
WORKING WITH AND- INCONVENIENCE
THEM RISK THEIR HEALTH SIX
CETERA- WELL WE'VE TRIED TO
CRAFT IS BLOWN AWAY THAT
BALANCES I KNOW THAT SOME OF
YOU HAVE BEEN TOLD THAT- THIS
WILL EXPAND THE ABILITY TO-
HANDLE SPECIALTY MEDICATIONS
YOU'RE CONCERNED ABOUT THAT LET
ME MAKE SURE YOU UNDERSTAND.
THERE'S NOTHING A CALIFORNIA
LAW THAT LIMITS THE ABILITY OF
PHARMACIES DEVELOP DISPENSED
ACTUALLY TRUCKS THE LIMITS ARE
BOTH TECHNOLOGICAL AND
LOGISTICAL AND THOSE WILL
REMAIN THERE ARE SOME
PHARMACIES THAT WILL NOT BE
ABLE TO DO CERTAIN THINGS THAT
WILL BE APPROPRIATE THEN TO
HAVE THOSE PATIENTS GO TO OTHER
PHARMACIES. BUT THE OPPOSITION
HIDES BEHIND THE TERM SPECIALTY
WHAT THEY MEAN AND WHAT THEY
ALWAYS MANAGED BY AND LARGE
WHEN THEY SAY THAT IS
EXPENSIVE. AND THEY ANT TO
CONTROL THE DISPENSING OF
EXPENSIVE DRUGS AND JUST
BECAUSE A DRUG IS EXPENSIVE AND
THEREFORE DESIGNATED STRICTLY
DRUG DOES NOT MEAN THAT OTHER
PHARMACIES CANNOT DISPENSE IT
IN FACT IN MANY INSTANCES HAVE
ALREADY BEEN DISPENSING IT WHEN
THE- PBM STEP IN AND SAY- WE
WANT YOU TO GO SOMEWHERE ELSE.
BUT WE THINK THIS BILL IS REPRO
CONSUMER AND WE ASKED HIM YES
WELL THANK YOU. THANK YOU FOR
MUCH WE'LL MOVE ON TO OUR SAID
WITNESS IN SOME. REPRESENTING
P. L. A. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CRACKPOTS A
PER ON BEHALF OF A QUE LA
HEALTH PLAN AT UHC IN ONE OF
THE LARGEST HIV SERVICE
PROVIDERS AND L. A. COUNTY-
TODAY I'M JUST GOING TO FOCUS
MY COMMENTS ON HOW PATIENTS
DURING IMPACTS. PEOPLE WITH HIV
AND OTHER CHRONIC CONDITIONS.
MOST IMPORTANTLY THIS PRACTICE
UNDERMINES THE REALLY CRITICAL
RELATIONSHIP BETWEEN PATIENTS
ON THE APARTMENT THAT. MANY
PATIENTS DEPENDS ON THIS
PERSONAL RELATIONSHIP SOMETIMES
SOMEONE THEY'VE KNOWN FOR YEARS
TO PROVIDE ACCURATE
INFORMATION. ABOUT SIDE EFFECTS
AND TO HELP THEM REMAIN
INSURANCE THEIR MEDICATION.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR
PEOPLE WITH HIV. AND OTHER
CHRONIC CONDITION. PATIENTS
HEARING COULD ALSO CREATE
SIGNIFICANT PRIVACY ISSUES
ESPECIALLY FOR YOUNG PEOPLE. OF
PEOPLE EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND THOSE LIVING IN
MORE RURAL AREAS. IF THE
PATIENT CAN'T PICK UP THEIR
MEDICATION AT THE PHARMACY OF
CHOICE. AND ESPECIALLY IF THEY
ARE REQUIRED TO USE MAIL ORDER.
SOMEONE COULD FIND OUT ABOUT
THEIR MEDICAL CONDITION WHICH
OF COURSE COULD HAVE DISASTROUS
CONSEQUENCES. AND IT CREEK
LIKELY. FOR THESE REASONS THE
MANDATORY MAIL ORDER HAS LONG
BEEN RECOGNIZED TO BE AN
APPROPRIATE. AND EVEN UNLAWFUL
FOR PEOPLE WITH HIV- AND LASTLY
JUST WANT TO STRESS THE
IMPORTANCE OF PATIENTS BEING
ABLE TO PICK UP THEIR
MEDICATION. AT A PHARMACY WHERE
APARTMENTS TO SPEAK THEIR
LANGUAGE AND WHERE THEY KNOW
THEY WILL RECEIVE CULTURALLY
COMPETENT CARE. AS A SURPRISE
TO NO ONE ON THE COMMITTEE NOT
HAVING THAT CULTURALLY
COMPETENT PROVIDER. IS ONE OF
THE BIGGEST REASONS THE PEOPLE
FALL OUT OF CARE. THIS IS
ESPECIALLY TRUE FOR LGBT PEOPLE
AND COMMUNITIES OF COLOR. AND
PATIENTS MUST HAVE THE OPTION
TO RECEIVE THEIR MEDICATION.
FROM THE PHARMACY WHERE THEY
KNOW THEY WILL RECEIVE
CULTURALLY COMPETENT CARE.
THANK YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY
URGE. YOUR SUPPORT PRESS
PEACOCK TWENTY FOUR. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I'M WOULD YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINES FOR ADDITIONAL
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC NOW JUST
SIMPLY TO SIGNIFY THEIR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU PRESS ONE ZERO PLEASE-
SILVERLIGHT AND NUMBER FORTY
THREE ISRAEL HAD. GOOD MORNING
ZACHARY CORBEAU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DENTAL ASSOCIATION
WE ARE IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
NEXT IN LINE FIFTY THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRANDON
MARCHING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
MEDICAL ASSOCIATION ALSO IN
SUPPORT. NEXT HEADLINE. FIFTY
FIVE. GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS PAT WHALEN ELLISON
WILSONAP MISTY HERE ON BEHALF
OF UNITED DISASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA THE YOU HEP IN
STRONG SUPPORT. AND EXPENSE
LINE FIFTY SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON
SHARE GONZALEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ON IT HERE COALITION
IS STRONG SUPPORT. AND
CURRENTLY NO FURTHER IN Q.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEEN
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT
WILL NOW MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION.
WHEN I MOVE ONTO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
LIMIT YOUR TESTIMONY TOMORROW
MORE THAN TWO MINUTES. WILL
BEGIN WITH A BILL HEAD FROM THE
DIVORCE WHERE TO FOUNDATION.
YOUR LOADMASTER FLOW FLOW AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS BILL HAVE A POSSIBLE
CARE MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO TESTIFY IN APOSITION OF
FIVE POINT SB FIVE TWENTY FOUR
TODAY I DO WANT TO BEGIN BY
THANKING BOTH THE CHAIR AND MR
CHI FOR ALL THE WORK ON THE
AMENDMENTS. AND THE BILL AND
THE VIRTUAL OPEN DOOR
THROUGHOUT THIS PROCESS IS VERY
MUCH APPRECIATED. HOWEVER WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE A CONCERN WITH
THE UNDERLYING BILL. FOR TWO
REASONS ONE IT IS IT TAKES AWAY
ONE OF THE IMPORTANT COST
SAVINGS TOOLS. AVAILABLE TO
HELP PLANS PROVIDED BY PBMS
THAT ENABLE THEM TO STRESS
THEIR HEALTHCARE DOLLARS AS FAR
AS POSSIBLE- UNDER THE GUIDANCE
OF YOU KNOW PATIENTS DURING-
WHICH WE DISAGREE WITH THE
PREMISE EVEN EXISTING. IT
REALLY COMES DOWN TO THE MARKET
SHARE TRYING TO GET MORE THE
MARKET SHARE SO LET'S HAVE A
LET'S HAVE AN OPEN DISCUSSION
ABOUT THAT BUT NOT DO IT UNDER
THE GUISE OF SOMETHING THAT
SIMPLY DOESN'T EXIST- SO. ALL
OF THOSE TOOLS GOING TO AT THE
OF THE DAY. IMPACT PREMIUM AND
COST FOR PATIENTS. THAT WITH
RESPECT TO. CARE THE- IT WAS
MENTIONED ABOUT HAAS- IMPACTING
THE DEFINITION SPECIALLY GET. I
WOULDN'T I WOULD ADD THAT. IT'S
A RATHER THAT COST THE ONLY
THAT THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
USES IN ITS DEFINITION. OF
ESPECIALLY TRUCKS SO WE THINK
IT IS RELEVANT FOR THIS
DEFINITION TO BE CONSISTENT
WITH FEDERAL REGULATIONS AS
WELL. ALSO SPECIALLY
PHARMACIES- OPEN PPO CONTRACTS
THAT REQUIRED TO RECEIVE
NATIONAL INDEPENDENT UNIFORM
ACCREDITATION STANDARDS. AND
THE PURPOSE OF THE STANDARDS IS
TO PROVIDE PATIENT PROTECTION.
SO IN THE ABSENCE OF THESE GIVE
US CONCERN IN THE DEFINITION OF
POTENTIALLY OPENING THE DOOR
FOR A NETWORK PHARMACY TO
DISPENSE WITH SPECIALLY DRUGS
EVEN THOUGH IT IS NOT BEEN
ACCREDITED. AND CONTRACTED HAS
A SPECIALTY PHARMACY AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE ARE SO
COMMITTEE TO VOTE NO ON THE
BILL THANK YOU MESSAGES THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR MOVE ON TO
PRESTON YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE.
YES GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PRESS ANY ON
FROM THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIVE TWENTY
FOUR PERSON FOREMOST I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE.
INVESTORS SHE FOR THE HARD WORK
TIME AND CONSIDERATION OF THIS
BILL WE DO REMAIN OPPOSED TO SB
FIVE TWENTY FOUR AND WHAT IS IN
PRINT TODAY. THE OVERARCHING
CONCERN THAT WE HAVE WITH THE
BILL IS THAT WOULD IT WOULD IT
WOULD GIVE ROAD THE INCENTIVE
EMPLOYERS HEALTH PLANS AND
INSURERS HAVE TO DESIGN A
PARTICIPATING PHARMACY
NETWORKS. NETWORKS INCLUDE MAIL
ORDER PHARMACIES CHAIN
PHARMACIES AND INDEPENDENT
PHARMACIES. MAY HELP CONTROL
PHARMACEUTICAL COSTS FOR
PATIENTS IN ADDITION TO
HEALTHCARE PREMIUMS FOR
EMPLOYERS AND EMPLOYEES. SB
FIVE TWENTY FOUR DISRUPTORS
BENEFIT DESIGN AND THE CHOICES
PLAN PARTICIPANTS MAKE TO
REDUCE PHARMACEUTICAL PRODUCTS
WHICH ARE SUBSTANTIAL.
ACCORDING TO THE DMH C. IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN PRESCRIPTION
DRUGS ACCOUNTED FOR TWELVE
POINT 7% OF TOTAL HEALTH PLAN
PREMIUMS. THE NUMBER OF
PATIENTS IN THESE NETWORKS ARE
REDUCED THE COST CONTROLS WILL
BE WEAKENED AND UNFORTUNATELY
WELL AS BEFORE TWENTY FOURTH
WELL INTENTIONED. THE LACK OF
THE HEALTHCARE COSTS RIGHT. IN
ADDITION ARE COST CONCERNS SB
FIVE TWENTY FOUR. IS ALSO OF
CONCERN AND- WE ARE IN
OPPOSITION BECAUSE IT HELPS TO
REGULATE HEALTH SELF INSURED
PLANS DESIGNED TO BENEFIT THIS
IS AN AREA SPACE GOVERNED BY
ARISSA AND IT'S FEDERALLY
PREEMPTED. SO FOR THESE REASONS
WE ARE OPPOSED SB. FIVE TWENTY
FOUR THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
TO. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. NUMBER
OF TO MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
WISHING TO SIGNIFY THEIR
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES
OPERATE IF WE TO PLEASE OPEN
THE LINES. FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC WISHING TO SIGNIFY THEIR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU AGAIN
IT'S ONE NINE ZERO FIRST WE'LL
GO TO LINE OF SEVENTEEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE SECURE MEMBERS
JOHN LINGER ON THE UP AMERICA'S
HEALTH INSURANCE PLANS.
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. NEXT WE
ARE LINE OF FIFTY I'M SORRY
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MR CHAIRMAN BIRTH
MIKE MONEY GOING TO BE OUT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSOCIATION OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS. CALIFORNIA
STATE PIPE TRADES COUNCIL AND
THE LEGISLATIVE COUNCIL OF
SHEET METAL WORKERS. OUR
CONCERN IS THAT THE BILL WOULD
CIRCUMVENT THE RICH THE
PREEMPTION OF OUR UNIONS TRUST
FUNDS THANK YOU. NEXT IN THE
LINE OF FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THIS
IS ERIN REID BURKE ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
LIFE AND HEALTH INSURANCE
COMPANIES AND PERFECT
COMPETITION. AND CURRENTLY NO
FURTHER IN Q. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SEE NO DIGITAL MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC WISHING TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS. THE NUMBER OF THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS HELLO BEGIN WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FONG FOLLOWED
BY SOME REMEMBER CHECK. I THINK
IT WAS CHAIR OF I JUST WANT TO
THANKS EVERY SKINNER FOR THE IN
DISCUSSION ON THIS ISSUE- THIS
BILL PROVIDES. A CONSUMER
CHOICE WHILE SUPPORTING LOCAL
PHARMACIES THAT BEST SERVE THE
NEEDS. OF MANY ROLE IN DISPATCH
COMMITTEES OF EXPORTING THIS
BILL TODAY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
SUMMER FONG. THE TAKE THAT
MAYBE PERHAPS OF THE MOTION.
GREAT A SIMILAR CHECK UP THANK
YOU MR APPRECIATE YOUR TIME A
REAL ONE THANK ALSO CENTER
SKINNER FOR THE OPPORTUNITY FOR
US TO HAVE THIS CONVERSATION. I
DO HAVE SOME QUESTIONS AS
REALLY APPRECIATE INTENT OF THE
BILL TO ADD ADDITIONAL ABILITY
FOR PEOPLE UTILIZE MEDICATION.
I ALSO UNDERSTAND TO THIS ON
THE OPPOSITION'S CONCERNS. THAT
WHEN THE ISSUES AND POINTS OF
CONTENTION IS. UTILIZATION
ESPECIALLY MEDICATIONS SO AS I
UNDERSTAND IN ORDER FOR YOU TO
BE. A SMASH ISSUES MAY
SPECIALTY MEDICATION PROVIDER
ONE HAS TO GO THROUGH AN
ACCREDITED ACCREDITATION
PROCESS AND IT IS CENTER
PATIENT SAFETY AND QUALITY
PURPOSES. FOR THE PHARMACIES
THAT HAVE NOT RECEIVED THIS
ACCREDITATION. IS THERE AN
ISSUE IN TERMS OF PATIENT
SAFETY QUALITY- DISPENSING- IF
YOU COULD- ASSISTANT THE ANSWER
THIS QUESTION APPRECIATED
SENATOR. THROUGH THE CHAIR
PLEASE SEVEN Q. THE BILL IF THE-
IF THE PARTICULAR PRESCRIPTION
CANNOT BE FILLED BY- THE
PHARMACY OF THE PATIENT'S
CHOICE UNDER THIS BILL AND IF
IT MAY OR MAY NOT BE A
SPECIALTY DRUG IT COULD BE A
DIFFERENT IT COULD. THERE IS A
VARIETY OF THAT EITHER
COMPOUNDED DRUGS ARE SUCH THAT
MAY NOT BE ABLE TO BE FILLED BY
A SAY IN INDEPENDENT PHARMACY
IN THE PHARMACY OF THE
PATIENT'S CHOICE SO OF COURSE
THEN THAT SPECIALTY PHARMACY
WOULD BE UTILIZED AND THERE'S
NOTHING IN THE BILL THAT WOULD
PREVENT THAT. AT ALL. THANK YOU
SENATOR. AND I ALSO HAVE
ANOTHER QUESTION- I ALSO
UNDERSTAND ONE OF THE POINTS OF
CONTENTION. FOR THE PHARMACIES
RELATES THE DEFINITION OF A
NETWORK SPECIALTY PHARMACY
SPECIFICALLY. WITH THE PURPOSE
TO ENSURE BE CONSISTENT WITH
THE STRANGE DEMANDS IMPOSED ON
PHARMACIES BY PBMS IMPLANTS.
GIVEN THE HIGH COSTS AND SINCE
THE NATURE OF THE MEDICATIONS.
GIVEN THAT IN MIND- CENTER HAS
THERE BEEN CONSIDERATIONS AND
DOCKING LANGUAGE. RELATING TO
THE DEFINITION OF A NETWORK
SPECIALTY PHARMACY- SINCE THIS
BILL ALLOWS FOR IN NETWORK
PHARMACIES S. DEFINED BY THE
HEALTH INSURER. WE DID NOT FEEL
THE NECESSITY TO ADD FURTHER-
DEFINITION AND IN TERMS OF THAT
ARGUMENT AROUND COST SO YOU
KNOW LET'S BE PRACTICAL THIS
BILL MAY BENEFIT SOME
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIES HOWEVER
THERE ARE SO FEW INDEPENDENT
PHARMACIES REMAINING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA THEY ARE
CERTAINLY NOT THE DRIVERS OF
HIGH PRESCRIPTION COSTS- SO TO.
TO IN THE FEW CASES WHERE A
PATIENT WOULD CHOOSE EITHER
BECAUSE SAY THEY LIVE IN A
RURAL AREA AND THE ONLY
PHARMACY NEARBY IS THAT
INDEPENDENT PHARMACY OR THEY
HAVE A LONG TERM RELATIONSHIP
WITH THAT INDEPENDENT FIRMS. SO
AS LONG AS THEY'RE IN NETWORK
IN A FEW CASES WHERE THE
PATIENT IS GOING TO UTILIZE
THAT PHARMACY INSTEAD OF. THE
ONE THAT THE PBM MIGHT PREFER
THEM TO USE IS NO WAY THAT THAT
IS DRIVING THE COST OF
PRESCRIPTIONS IN THE STATE. AND
DINNER REALLY PRISONER TIME
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND THANK YOU TO THE
AUTHOR FOR YOUR GOOD WORK ON
THIS BILL- THERE IS- A PART
WHERE IT TALKS ABOUT- A VERY
NARROW EXEMPTIONS SPECIALTY
DRUGS- WITH IN THE DEFINITION
OF- PATIENT STEERING RIGHT AND
DOES THAT ALIGN OR OR CREATE A
CONFLICT BETWEEN. THE
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN PBMS AND
PHARMACIES. WELL DONE. NOT TO
MY KNOWLEDGE. AND CERTAINLY WAS
NOT BROUGHT OUT FAR EITHER IN
ANALYSIS OR- AND PARTLY BECAUSE
CLEARLY IF YOU CANNOT IF THE
SPECIALTY DRUG THAT YOU HAVE
BEEN PRESCRIBED CANNOT BE
FILLED BY THE PHARMACY THAT YOU
MAY BE YOUR CHOICE. YOU
OBVIOUSLY WOULD NEED TO GO TO
THE SPECIALTY PHARMACY THAT THE
PRESCRIPTION BENEFIT MANAGER
HAS CHOSEN SO. THE- HI I HAVE A
DIFFICULT TIME UNDERSTANDING
WHAT IS PERCEIVED TO BE A
CONFLICT THERE. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ANSWER THANKS FOR YOUR
WORKTHANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AS OUR GRAYSON AND
ADDITIONAL QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS AT THIS TIME. SENATOR
SKINNER JEWISH TO CLOSE THANK
YOU I'M I WOULD JUST SAY IN MY
CLOSING THAT I FOUND IT
INTERESTING TO HAVE THE CHAMBER
OPPOSE. THE BILL BECAUSE IN
WHILE IT IS BEEN CHARACTERIZED
THAT THE BILL IS CONSUMER
FRIENDLY WHICH IT IS IT IS ALSO
VERY BUSINESS FRIENDLY. NOW WHY
ITS BUSINESS FRIENDLY IS
BECAUSE- IT SUPPORTS AND WE THE
LEGISLATURE PURPORT TO SUPPORT
SMALL BUSINESSES. BUT WHAT IT
DOES IS HELP TO ENSURE. THAT IN
THOSE FEW CASES WHERE. THE
PATIENT WANTS TO USE THE
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIST IF THAT
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIST IS IN
THE NETWORK. THEY CAN DO SO.
AND THE PRESCRIPTION BENEFIT
MANAGER CANNOT EXCLUDE THEM.
AND SO IN OTHER WORDS IT'S
SUPPORTING OUR SMALL BUSINESSES
NOW OVER TIME WE MAY FIND A
SITUATION. WHERE MANY OF OUR
HEALTH INSURERS DO NOT INCLUDE
INDEPENDENT PHARMACIES IN THE
NETWORK. BUT WHILE THEY ARE IN
THE NETWORK. THEN WE SHOULD NOT
HAVE LAWS THAT IN EFFECT.
FURTHER DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
THEM OTHER THAN OUR CHOI YOU
KNOW THAN. WHATEVER OTHER
MARKET FORCES MAY MAY AFFECT
THEIR EXISTENCE- AND WITH THAT
I ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS AS
AMENDED. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
CENTER SKINNER FOR ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE MADMAN'S UNITE
COMMITTEE COMMUNICATED ALSO
OVER THE HOLIDAY WEEKEND ON
THIS AND SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HARD WORK AND DEDICATION
FOR YOU SPECIFICALLY AS THE
AUTHOR AS WELL AS YOUR
DEDICATED STAFF. WORKING
COLLABORATIVELY WITH THE
COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC DISTRICT
THE POLICY FOR THE OUTCOMES FOR
ALL CALIFORNIANS WITH THAT AND
THERE'S BEEN A MOTION BY THE
SUMMER FONG AND SECOND BY
SIMPLY WERE IRWIN. COMMITTEE
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
SB FIVE TO FOUR SKINNER TO PASS
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
LOW I. LOW HI. FOR NOT VOTING
BERMAN BERMAN I BLOOM BLOOM HI
CHEN. CAN NOT VOTING ISSUE.
CUNNINGHAM. CUNNINGHAM NOT
VOTING TALLY. FONG. FONG HI
GIPSON. GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN IRWIN
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA HI MULLIN MULLIN I SALAS
SALAS. EIGHTEEN WEBER. WEBER HI.
TWELVE AYE SERRANO'S TELEVISED
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CENTER SKINNER. HOGS
WERE JUST- HAVE ONE MORE ITEM
ON THE AGENDA. AND THAT'S. FILE
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN SB 509% A
WILK AND HE'S ON HIS WAY.
AMAZING ANOTHER ADDRESS YOU.
YOU KNOW HAS BEEN A BIG
DIFFERENCE. YEAH.
COLLEAGUES
WILL MOVE ON TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER EVEN THIS IS SB FIVE
ZERO NINE BY SENATOR WILK
CENTER WHAT THIS DOES ENJOY DO
PASS RECOMMENDATION OF BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLE PLEASE FEEL
FREE TO PRESENT WHENEVER YOU'RE
READY GOOD AT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS BEFORE YOU
TODAY'S SB FIVE OH NINE WHICH
MAKES IT EASIER FOR OPTOMETRY
STUDENTS TO BEGIN WORKING IN
PAYING OFF THEIR STUDENT DEBTS
DURING THE PANDEMIC THE
PANDEMIC HAS AFFECTED EVERY
ASPECT OF OUR LIVES DURING THE
PAST YEAR AND HAS ESPECIALLY
HARMFUL IMPACT UNDERSTATES.
STUDENTS FOR INSTANCE. MANY OF
CALIFORNIA'S OPTOMETRY STUDENTS
HAVE BEEN UNABLE TO TRAVEL TO
NORTH CAROLINA. TO TAKE THE
REQUIRE REQUIRE PRACTICAL EXAM.
PREVENTING THEM FROM OBTAINING
THEIR LICENSES FROM GETTING A
HEAD START ON PAYING OFF THEIR
STUDENT DEBT. THIS BILL
PROVIDES A NARROW SOLUTION TO
ENABLE THOSE STUDENTS TO OBTAIN
A TEMPORARY LICENSE. IN BEGIN
WORKING UNDER THE DIRECT
SUPERIMPOSES GIN. OF A FULLY
LICENSED OPTOMETRIST. WITH ME
TODAY TO PROVIDE EXPERT
TESTIMONY IN FURTHER DRESS ANY.
QUESTIONS THAT THE COMMITTEE
MAY HAVE ITS TERRY MCHALE WITH
ERIN REED AND ASSOCIATES.
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
OPTOMETRIC ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. LEVINE TO PRIME
AWARENESS AND SUPPORT MR
MCHALE. FROM THE CALIFORNIA
OPTOMETRIC ASSOCIATION. MISTER
CHAIRMAN JERRY MAKAYLA THE
CALIFORNIA CONNECTICUT SAYS
PATIENT. THIS PROVISIONAL
LICENSE INSENSIBLE IT DOES HAVE
RESTRICTIONS IT DOES REQUIRE
THAT THE OPTOMETRIST WORK UNDER
THE DIRECT SUPERVISION OF AN
OPTOMETRIST'S NOT FOLLOW UP THE
MILEAGES THREE PHYSICALLY
PRESENT AT THE FACILITY WILL
ALLOW THE OPTOMETRIST TO BEGIN
PRACTICING BEGIN PAYING OFF
STUDENT LOANS TO BEGIN PAYING
OFF THEIR OWN LIFE EXPENSES.
AND THAT THIS LEGISLATION IS A
SMART WAY TO DEAL WITH WHAT
THIS CRISIS OF CONFIDENCE NOT
UPON US AND WE ASK FOR AN AYE.
VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. I
WOULD YOU OPEN OF THE LINE
FRIEND ADDITIONAL MAY OF THE
PUBLIC TO SIGNIFY THEIR SUPPORT.
THANK YOU PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO
IT'S SO. THANK YOU AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU VERY MUCH SEE NO
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING THE CHAMBERS
WISHING TO SPEAK IN SOME PART
WHEN I MOVE ON TO OPPOSITION
OPERATOR WOULD YOU PLEASE UP
THE BLINDS FOR MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC TO SIGNIFY THEIR
OPPOSITION. WANT TO GET IT ONE
AND THEN GENERAL TO TEST OPPOSE.
THEY CURRENTLY NINETY Q. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH OF THE
CONVERSATION BACK TO MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE FOR ANY.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
CINEQUEST OF THE COMMENTS OF
THE SELLER CHEN. I ENCOURAGE MY
VOTE CENTERS THAT WILL CAUSE A
PERSONAL HERO AND MY PERSONAL
MIND THE WALKING BOOT OF ALL
THINGS GOOD. AND- I- SAY A VOTE
FOR THIS IS A VOTE FOR GOODNESS
IN HUMANITY SO PLEASE SUPPORT
THIS BILL. DID DID. ASSEMBLY
ATTENDED JUST FOR PART OF IT
DID I HEAR YOU SAY BUDDHA. DID
YOU SAY PUT UP. KIMBER MISTER
CHOCKING BUDDHA WALKING BUDDHA
JUST FOR CLARIFICATION THE MASK
OR DIFFICULT HERE THANK YOU FOR
THE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
THANK YOU I'LL TAKE THAT AS A
SECOND VICE FLOOR. USER WORK I
JUST APPRECIATE YOU GRACE US
WITH YOUR PRESENCE HERE ON THE
GREEN CARPET YOU KNOW HAS A
LEADER IN THE SENATE YOU KNOW
IT'S JUST AN HONOR TO HAVE YOU
ARE PRESENT SO THANK YOU FOR
THIS. GLORIOUS PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. YEAH ANY
ADDITIONAL. GRILLING FROM THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AT
THIS POINT IN TIME. C. NINE
SENATOR WEALTHY WAS TOO CLOSE
SURE- APPRECIATE THE COMMENTS
FOR MY FUTURE COLLEAGUES HE
SEEMED TO ME THAT THERE SENATE
MATERIAL AND WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COMMITTEE SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. SB FIVE OH NINE WILL
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS LOW
HIGH LOW HIGH FLORA. FLORA ALL
RIGHT BERMAN. BERMAN HI BLOOM
BLOOM HI CHEN CHEN HI CHIU.
CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM I. DELI
DELI HI FONG FONG ALL RIGHT
GIPSON. GRAYSON GRAYSON AYE
HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN. IRWIN
AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY MEDINA.
MULLIN MULLIN I SALAS SALAS I
EIGHTEEN. WEBER. FORTY NINE
ZERO KNOWS FOURTEEN ISER DOES
BELIEVE THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ADDITIONAL MEMBERS THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBER THANK
YOU VERY MUCH CENTER WELL
COLLEAGUES THAT CONCLUDES THAT
JENNIFER TODAY WILL LEAVE THE
ROLE OPEN FOR. MEMBERS TO ADD
ON.
YEAH I THINK. YEAH. CONSENT
ITEM S. B. TWO SIX THREE TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS RUBIO
CHIU. CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
FIVE GRAYSON. GRAYSON HI HOLDEN.
HOLDEN HI. MCCARTY. MCCARTY HI
SALAS SALAS. EIGHTEEN SEVENTEEN
EYES ZERONOS. SB FOUR OH NINE
CABALLERO DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN BERMAN I
BLOOM. BLOOM. HI SHE YOU ARE
CHIU AYE CUNNINGHAM CUNNINGHAM
HI HOLDEN HOLDEN AYE IRWIN
IRWIN AYE MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE
MULLIN. MULLIN I SALAS SALAS HI
TEAM. EIGHTEEN I ZERO KNOWS. SB
SEVEN FIVE SEVEN ONE MON TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS BERMAN
BERMAN HI QIU QIU HI CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I. HOLDEN. IRWIN
IRWIN HI MCCARTY MCCARTY HI
MULLIN. MULLIN HI SALAS SALAS
HI TEAM. HOLDEN HOLDEN I.
NINETEEN ZERO KNOWS. SB THREE
SIX TWO NEWMAN TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CHEN.
QIU CHIU HI CUNNINGHAM
CUNNINGHAM I'D GRAYSON GRAYSON
AYE HOLDEN. HOLDEN I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY MCCARTY HI SALAS SALAS
ALL RIGHT TEAM. SEVENTY NINE
ZERO KNOWS. CHU CHU HI MCCARTY
MCCARTY AYE SALAS SALAS.
EIGHTEEN FIFTEEN AYE AYES TO
NOES.
SB FIVE TO FOUR SKINNER
QIU. TWO FIVE. DOLLY DRAWLING
NOW GIPSON YES I GIPSON HI TEAM.
FOURTEEN FIVE ONE NOW. AND SB
FIVE OH NINE WILK SHE YOU. CHIU
HI GIPSON GIPSON I MEDINA. SB
FIVE OH NINE WILK MEDINA HI.
CHANGE WEBER WEBER BY. EIGHTEEN
AYE ZERONOS. SB TWO SIX THREE
RUBIO DO PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS TANG TANG I.
EIGHTEEN ZERO KNOWS. SB FOUR OH
NINE CABALLERO D. PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS TANG.
KING I NINETEEN EYES ZERONOS.
SB SEVEN FIVE SEVEN MON TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS TING TING I.
NINETY NINE ZERO KNOWS. SB
THREE SIX TWO NEWMAN TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS TANK.
KING I EIGHTY NINE ZERO KNOWS.
SB THREE OH SIX PAN. TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS TANG TANG I
SIXTEEN AYE AYES TO NOES. SB
FIVE TO FOUR SKINNER D. PASSES
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS TANG
TANG I FIFTEEN EYES ONE NOW. SB
FIVE OH NINE WILL BE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS TANG TANG I
NINETEEN ZERO KNOWS. YEAH.
LATER ON. THANK YOU SO MUCH OF.
YEAH S. B. TWO SIX THREE RUBIO
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS QIU
QIU I. NINETY NINE ZERO KNOWS.
TROPICANA IT'S GOING. YEAH.
YEAH AND THEN I'M GONNA. WE ARE
CURRENTLY.